c'est la première fois que je fait ce
genre de footy megal tu penses vraiment
que je vais croire que je suis ton
premier trou d'inscrire ce tag est
encore le cliché de la fifa s'il habite
alors que nuit soir en lançant voir ravi
d'avoir couché avec toi eh ben dis donc
un bon panel et j'espère que vous n'avez
pas besoin de vous déplacer dans les
heures qui suivent nous sommes face à
des chutes de neige très ambitieux je
peux pas rester si c'est l'enfer sur ta
écoute ma chérie europe sur toi combien
de sauver des compos non c'est vrai que
ça m'a demandé
[Musique]
à bavay
utilisez ce laps de temps pour se donner
des conseils on a personne qui viendra
après tu crois avoir des conseils pour
moi moment où tu te déshabille pour être
un peu plus et j'ai fait tomber ma
petite culotte c'est un mystère tu n'as
pas de copie c'était donc ta première
aventure d'un soir
en général ça dure pas aussi bon
j'arrive pas à croire que je ne
travaillais jusqu'à brooklyn pour un
plan cul je crois que ça se prépare
non non c'est la dsi
[Musique]